he's been here a couple of times before
man it's not his first football rodeo
here in Brian banks we'll talk about
that in a second I love city on a hill
on show time starring this man Aldous
Hodge you get to see you sir
let's talk about this film Brian banks
it's an important story it's a crucial
story you know very well last time you
were here was with Brian right and now
it's finally coming to a theater near
you his story of being falsely accused
of rape by a high school classmate in
2002 he was set to maybe go to USC and
ball out from Long Beach Poly just like
Willie McGinest and others before him
his life turned upside down and this
story is totally bonkers it's an insane
story very much so what was it like
playing Brian well for me it was
fantastic because I feel like Brian's
path is so unique in that what he went
through
it happens to a lot of people but how he
used it how he went through it the way
that he made it something effective in
the most positive way I think that was
really a part of his journey so this
film for me is like oh we get to be an
asset to his purpose in life inspiring
people inspiring that progressive
conversation have changed you just
reaffirmed all that so being able to
step inside of his mind was really
honestly a privilege man in doing the
scenes I would talk to him we would go
all the way back to those moments so
sometimes it got a little deep it got a
little tough but he was always willing
and ready and available to just sort of
give me that experience to give me the
tools I needed to execute but for me
with everything that we did even when
the times got rough we had to shoot
rougher scenes I'd go to those dark
places I said all right this is going to
hopefully inspire some what somebody
should do some work right so it was just
it was a great privilege and man what an
experience brother yeah and then the
film is a terrific portrayal of the
story and the aunt is and you're
terrific and it's Oh Brian is on a set
you're going places that he
it's difficult clearly for him to
revisit and you're going to those places
on his behalf I mean what the world is
absolutely to be the the scene that we
just played Wow that we were shooting
that day and I you know talked to Brian
said and took him aside a minutes like
brother like I'm really kind of having
I'm struggling to find the right notes
here like talk to me what was this for
you wouldn't you know and we went all
the way back through what it was like
for home life and his mom's and all that
kind of stuff and honestly we were just
to do sitting outside on a stairwell
like don't do memory road a crying about
know the experiences because we were
sharing are both of our hardships in
life and you know happiness but it kind
of solidified the Brotherhood in a
completely different way but it was
awesome because you know I had to step
into it in order to understand how to
portray that sense of empathy mercy
because the thing about this movie the
one thing they get right is Brian is a
walking ball of light he is nothing if
not the personification of inspiration
right so I wanted people to understand
that and get that from him and from
watching his film because you know if
you don't understand that he's a great
human being coming off this film that I
have done a disservice to the bay I mean
you could see he does I mean he's
because again again we've met him we met
him on the show and what when did he
come on our podcast Chris was it like
Tom yeah it was early on 2011 2012 so I
mean and so we I kind of knew his story
yeah and then he sat on our podcast
which I would love for people to see if
you want to go listen to just telling
about how he was gonna go to USC and he
was gonna be a star Baccarin : he's real
all right scholars to go from the man
Pete Carroll himself gave him verbal
confirmation you coming and so I
automatically as 16 see all of your
football dreams guaranteed you know the
way I took a plea deal that he shouldn't
have taken yeah and and
and then he goes to prison for five
years and he gets out and he's trying to
as he's on parole he's trying to clear
his name - he said the ankle bracelet
comes off and he doesn't have to be a
registered sex offender and he can go
about his business maybe maybe if any
any shot at playing football again he's
got to do it yeah and here's the thing
that people have to understand like he
was accused of 16 he spent a year in
juvie fighting the case so he was
already in custody locked up you know
for a minute before you know he got the
sentence when he got the sentence I
think he went to prison like a day after
his 18th birthday you know so here's a
baby going at the prison like prison in
jail are two different things but he's
going to prison with monsters five years
prison in five years on parole as a
registered sex offender wearing the
ankle monitor which means he's still
technically in prison in public it was
nauseating to understand all that he
went through and the turn of the case
all this object plays Brian banks to
turn in the case again is he gets
facebook friended by the accused like
like there was nothing's going through
your mind not like nothing had ever
happened like did you not did you forget
all that and again my concern with the
movie is that people are gonna say that
that can't be real like you just made
that up but that's so actually it is all
documents and that was a big break for
him because he eventually got a
recantation yeah and you can still find
that on YouTube the real live video the
real recantation you can find that on
YouTube right now so it's very much real
if y'all want to find out go look it up
and obviously it's also part of the
journey for Brian banks in this film all
this and I was blown away because he's
not credited either in the film it when
the scenes in prison where he's
basically trying to be helped through
his bitterness this clear obvious and
understandable bitterness about what's
happened Morgan Freeman pops up in this
villain what was that like shooting
scenes with Morgan
for you well it's it was I'm not gonna
lie man I don't really get starstruck or
anything like that I don't really but
this is this is a different sort of
experience he's a legend you know he's
one of the goats and I'll tell you
something that really brought me to
tears working with mr. Freeman so he has
a history with Tom Shadyac the Bruce
Almighty films and you know they yeah so
there they go back man they're the good
old friends the very first day mr.
freeman and i are shooting we hadn't
spoken really socially you know hey how
you done but we get straight to work and
we're barely even speaking in the same
but after a couple takes he goes he
whispers to something Tom Tom pulls me
over he says hey man I wanna tell you
some real quick that uh Morgan Morgan
you know wanted to tell me he said you
know that kid over there he's got it huh
bro that broke me in two seconds because
I was so nervous on this film I remember
there were days I didn't feel like I was
pulling my weight and I would call my
brother in black bro I don't know if I'm
you know doing my thing my brother Edwin
Hodge she's a fantastic actor he's not
one of the reasons I became an actor you
know and he would be like bro you got
the confidence man I mean you could just
you know keep your head up you know I
would call I'm a mom my friends would
send me notes on it on a regular basis
just to keep my confidence up because
this was the the responsibility was
heavy for me so every single day you
know I was like damn it my doing my work
and to be in you know 30 minutes of
shooting into a scene for mr. Freeman to
say something like that about me was all
the confidence in the world now I was
like wow that is shook me man and I hate
I don't mean to say this story that out
of a sense of vanity that that's not you
know but but it was absolute validation
in a completely different way and bro I
was like I was all of my feelings I was
an emotional
dry shed of thugs here I'm not gonna lie
I should have thugs here you know what I
mean you know that's cool
it's all right you know but that man
because the to me this story we have to
get it right because it speaks to such a
large conversation that's going on right
now especially in the space of judicial
reform especially with what the CIP does
they're working on all kinds of cases
people in there who are falsely accused
of you know murder and right yeah all
these different charged the California
Innocence profile for Nia Innocence
Project get started by a that's helmed
by Justin Brooks who you know he does
these cases pro bono he does not charge
people for this one that's who Greg
Kinnear plays in this for yeah and there
are some cases that Justin's been
working on for over 20 years over 23 25
years like you know to think of putting
that much effort and dedication into
something that you just have that faith
in and you're not asking for a cent from
it you know your heart is it you know
what I mean and Brian still works with
the CIP sits on the board so I think
this was too important to mess up and at
no point was it about any of us
individually everybody came to this with
heart our producers our director our
actors everybody came to it with heart
because they knew how serious is this
could be and what it could mean and we
just wanted to get it there well you
meet Brian banks for five minutes you
know that's what he's all about so
clearly you you you were picking up from
his vibe yeah there's no doubt about
that yeah there's no question all
massage here on the Rich Eisen show all
right let's talk about some other stuff
here as well sitting on a hill I mean it
er you are joking this sir
this is a great I mean we had Kevin
Bacon on a couple of weeks yeah it is
okay bizzle I mean oh-kay pizzle is that
is that what you call him yeah I love
that came up with that name we were
joking around and that that ended up
being that's that's what his name is in
my phone okay seven seven degrees of me
you know so so my good friend who's also
my barber on this his name is art
Williams
that's my do right it's my ace and
I think we were messing around one day
we joking with Kevin and that kind of
came up spring that's what it is but man
it's a monster show with a monster cast
it is you have a fantastic producing
team I'm actually a fan of the show when
I say that I mean outside of bias of me
being a part of it right I like the show
I'm wondering where it's going but now I
could say no III it is just you know
you've seen so many shows movies set in
Boston set in Boston where not
everybody's acting properly right you're
seeing so many this is in it's
remarkable how this show and you and
everyone else has found something a
unique sort of new fingerprint for it
it does remind me a lot of obviously the
producing team along with you know Damon
and Affleck is Oz there is a lot of wire
there's a wire element totally got that
it really really does run oh man Tom
Fontana obviously mr. Ives
he is mr. Oz is fantastic you know and
he's you know really really taking the
reins of driving us down the right the
right path but you know really it kind
of starts with ends with his use is
really sort of led by Chuck McLean our
show creator Chuck is Boston on a
percent in and out hey you were saying
he'd be good guest on this show I think
he would be I think you should have
Chuck joke with you I'm like so let me
guess he's a patriot fan Celtics Bruins
little bean pot please say something
about boss please you gonna get you Oh
Chuck is awesome man but he's super
doubt then he's a smart cat really
collaborative I think which is his
superpower when it comes to this show
but you know he pulls no punches he just
kind of goes for his mind just it just
it's right there so on the page and
we're seeing it we just man we got lucky
with a really fantastic team and then of
course you know okay hey
you know got a lot of you got a lot of
fans of the show right here on the show
also in our our control room as well a
couple of minutes with all this odds
right here so again Brian banks is not
your first football if you will do
voodoo Tatom say did you ever play
football
never once I didn't flip over no not
even in the street not even some like so
was Friday Night Lights your first ever
football attempt yeah get out of here
that's like our guide l to fo making a
hole-in-one in his first ever golf swing
are you serious
now my sport coming up was fighting I
still fight today I love to try and use
to compete but when it came to football
my brother was the football player he
loved football my Papa loved football I
was the rebellious science nerd so I was
like I just want to hit stuff and make
science projects what was your best
science project on us what I'm working
on right now making watches well I'm a
watchmaker Maharaja's that's my other
job you're a neurologist neurologist
okay I'll be honest with you that's a
big word alert right there but check
this out though so like in Austin where
we shot Friday Night Lights like
everybody lives eats sleeps briefs
football you'll find six-year-old girls
who know more about football than some
of y'all do all right ma I remember
shooting one day I throw up passed it
was so terrible and the next day
literally the next day in the papers the
headline front page was how I threw a
duck of a pass like y'all gonna put your
boy out because I'm supposed to be the
star quarterback right bad your food
retailer
yeah and they had this great quarterback
from UT's and his actual name is James
Brown
he's from UT teaching me but they put
your boy out there to my business was
I'm like no no me up I got to walk
around in you know well word was
is on the set of the film Friday Night
Lights right wasn't it that that P Diddy
was gonna be the quarterback and Oh any
given Sunday any given Sunday that's
what it was
and they saw P did he throw and P to P
did he did not appear to this is in then
that's did that sound Jamie Foxx could
well he can act he can also throw it
he'll play yeah cuz I think he might
have played in his early years but he
would say I saw an interview with Jamie
Foxx for saying that talking about an
in-game Sunday where he said you know
he'd get down there you really got to
play football cuz they do have you out
there when we were doing Friday Night
Lights first couple weeks was training
camp we sitting out there in the middle
of summer and Austin our cleats on the
on the high ground was like our feet
were probably sitting on a hundred one
hundred thirteen hundred twenty degree
heat yeah it was a it was I mean our
days of lightning I knew whatever but
the heat coming off the ground was
insane and I cleats our tape to our feet
so we cannot take them off we're sitting
in chairs like this just you know like
save me please but we did real training
so I got in shape I think I would have
been a better quarterback or running
babe I'd like to be a linebacker that
just seems fun but while you were there
I was in this film you weren't yeah I
trained there Brian was straight at me
it's not an easy position but again I go
fighting so you know if I see a target
to go hit I'm gonna go hit it well let's
let's find that headline rider in Austin
Texas you try and make a watch also okay
that's exactly you're a watchmaker make
a watch you're a [ __ ] ologist right
Riley I had no idea Brian banks in the
theaters near you on Friday August 9th
city on a hill on Showtime on Sunday
nights it is absolutely worth your watch
you are awesome Aldous Hodge thanks for
coming in you are as well brother
anytime come back anytime for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download
Rich Eisen show app